everyone's favorite frightening doll is
back and we're not talking about Chucky
we're talking about Annabelle the messed
up face of the conjuring universe
according to critics this creepy toys
third spin-off movie Annabelle comes
home looks like another big winner for
the horror franchise
congratulations Annabelle well there was
a moratorium on full reviews being
published in the lead-up to the movie's
release and about comes home was
screened in advance for a few select
critics and their early reactions on
Twitter were pretty positive the general
consensus series writer Gary Doberman
making his directorial debut with this
threequel has delivered an atmospheric
creepy thrill ride that easily bests the
previous Annabelle flicks in terms of
flat-out fun rather than focusing on the
dolls origins and decades past like the
previous two films Annabelle comes home
brings things well home tying itself in
with the original conjuring series much
more closely than the spin-off series
has before the movie predominantly
features the demonologist Lorraine and
Edie Warren the main characters in the
conjuring and sequel Annabelle comes
home chronicles the terrifying events
that unfold when the Warrens sequester
the doll inside their artifacts room for
safekeeping only to find out that her
presence has some unexpected and rather
unfortunate consequences it's a beacon
for spirits in this movie Annabelle and
these other spirits all pose a grave
threat to the warrens young daughter
Judy as well as a pair of particularly
unlucky babysitter's who've been tasked
with watching over her attempting to
describe the film conjuring universe
mastermind James Wan said it's basically
a Night at the Museum with Annabelle the
critics who caught preview screenings of
Annabelle comes home generally agreed
that the film is just as fun and
over-the-top as Juan's description
suggests cinema blends Eric Eisenberg
claims that the Annabelle series just
keeps getting better and better the
critic wrote excited I can now say
Annabelle comes home as excellent
solidifying the trilogy as a rare one
that improves with each sequel the cast
is fantastic the monster mayhem is
surprisingly clever and the whole
experience is just super fun it's a big
win for the conjuring universe Silas
Lesnick a movie Bill was pleased to
report that the new crop of spirits
didn't feel forced thanks to some smart
narrative choices on
to report that Annabelle comes home is
great it has a smart script fantastic
performances and it expands the
conjuring universe in some really clever
ways mostly though it's just a ton of
fun Erik Francisco of inverse was
similarly impressed with the film's
array of supernatural threats calling
the movie an atmospheric thrill that
cements the conjuring franchise as the
horror movie universe to reckon with
there's plenty more than just parlor
tricks in the Warrens is forbidden room
than you might expect
while Juan's Night at the Museum
comparison makes for an enticing blender
pitch fandango's erik davis compared the
horror film to another quirky comedy one
which might make you even more excited
to see what the movie hasn't stored
he wrote Annabelle comes home is like
adventures in babysitting as a horror
movie and it's a damn good time the
scares are never repetitive the humor is
on point and there are plenty of creepy
entities to freak you out plus I love
movies where it's up to the babysitter
to save the day finally Dredd Central's
Jonathan bark Colin weighed in on the
film and while he was careful to avoid
spoilers he offered up a few general
thoughts on Twitter saying seriously I
loved this movie had a genuine blast
with it and I can't recommend it enough
of course he might be saying that
because of the special guest he says he
saw the screening with well the
consensus may change as more reviews
come in the early buzz is unanimous
Annabelle comes home is a bonafide
success and potentially a high point for
the whole conjuring franchise
take a bow Annabelle check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
horror films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one